- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the major
problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is Be Truly Fulfilled.
Over to you, Tony Robbins.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Michael Gerber, the guy
that wrote the E-Myths,
you know it talks about
why so many businesses,
young businesses, fail and
one of the things he says
is most people are not
really entrepreneurs
but they think that's what they should be.
They think that's the sexy thing.
That's the most attractive thing,
that's the best answer.
And what I say to you is you've
got to separate the vehicle
from the outcome.
What is it that's going
to truly fulfill you?
What is it that's going to give
you that extraordinary life?
What's going to make things
magnificent on your terms?
Not somebody else's terms.
Not your father, your
mother, your background.
What is that really?
Separate the vehicle,
because there's many ways
to get to that vehicle.
But I'm saying, sometimes
you got to reevaluate
what's going to really make you fulfilled.
What is your gift?
Are you an artist?
Are you the talent that
can produce something
no one else produces?
A skill, or product, or a
service, or some impact?
Are you incredibly good at management?
You really know how to
manage or lead people?
Are you an extraordinary entrepreneur
that can take that
gigantic gut load of risk?
And can create the vision
and attract the talent
that you need and the
managers and leaders?
You may have all three abilities,
but which one really fulfills you the most
is going to be the critical question.
Cause we tend to want to do them all,
especially in a room like this.
Cause you're all overachievers, right?
Me, too.
And you say I can do all these.
Yes you can, but what will it
do to your quality of life?
See again, the secret's going to be this.
What is an extraordinary
life on your terms today?
Getting clear about that,
at this stage of life,
where you are, where you want to go.
- I think it's really
important to build a life
that you are running towards
instead of running away
from something that you don't like.
Let me explain.
I think people are hard
wired to avoid pain
more than to go out and seek pleasure.
There's been tons of studies
that have talked about it.
People don't like pain.
We love pleasure, but we hate pain
more than we love pleasure.
And so how that often
translates into entrepreneurship
is people are acting not
out of a desire to go off
and do something big and impactful,
but out of fear of pain and
trying to reduce the pain
as much as possible.
I've talked to so many
entrepreneurs and I asked them,
"Why did you start this business?
"Why is it so important to you?
"What's the reason behind it?"
And whenever I get an answer like,
"I really hated my last job.
"My boss was really terrible.
"I just wanted freedom and
I need to set my own hours."
If that's why you're
starting the business,
you're going to fail.
Cause you're just running
away from a painful life
and you think entrepreneurship
is the answer.
And those are not the
successful entrepreneurs.
The successful entrepreneurs are the ones
who are going to embrace
the pain that comes along
with building the business,
and they want the pleasure
so much of going off and building
this really important thing.
Every time I make a video on YouTube,
there's a lot of pain associated with it.
There's comments that come
in that may not be great.
There's work to come out research it
and make this happen for you guys.
But we push through it, because
I want to have an impact.
Cause I want the work that I do to matter.
And so I would examine
your reasons for wanting
to make that change in your
life or in your business.
Ask yourself why am I doing it.
If it's just to avoid something
and run away from a life
that you don't like,
that's not the answer.
You've got to run toward
something that you're in love with
and you want to build and
you want to see come to life.
Stop running away from your problems,
and go build something that means it.
So the question today is, I'm curious.
Which one are you?
Did you start your business to run away
from problems you had in your life?
Or are you trying to build
something for the future?
Really curious to find out.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Tim Miller.
Tim, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
I really really appreciate it, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Can we, help us appreciate
this early experience,
these lean years, these
very difficult years
leading up to the ultimate prize.
- There is no prize
out there.
The only prize is this
one and what you feel,
and what you want to accomplish.
And if you can,
as you start out,
these what could be lean years
or could be fat years.
I feel that I very often
watch a lot of young people
sort of meander around
without any idea about why
they're doing what they're doing.
I mean to want, and to be ambitious,
and to want to be
successful is not enough.
That's just desire.
To know what you want, to
understand why you're doing it,
to dedicate every breath
in your body to achieve.
If you feel you have
something to give, if you feel
that your particular
talent is worth developing,
is worth caring for,
then there's nothing you can't achieve.
- [Audience Member] How would
you describe fulfillment
as a YouTube producer?
- Well, I think fulfillment,
fulfillment and YouTube producer are
kind of two different things.
I think fulfillment in
general as a film maker for me
comes from creating.
And that's why in 2010 ...
They put the soundtrack on for this story,
so I'll try to make it sound nostalgic.
I left the mainstream sort of universe
because I wanted to create more.
So for me fulfillment comes in creation
and I always say that I'm
a little bit of a junkie
and my drug is uploading.
Because if I haven't posted
a movie in like a month
or a month and a half, I get
like seriously depressed.
And the only thing that makes me happy
is to get a new movie out there.
That answers your question, right?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- I've never really been interested
in living a balanced life.
I think balanced people
don't change the world,
first of all.
I think balanced people
don't really follow a dream.
This doesn't mean that you
don't have responsibilities.
Like to go the other part of his question,
"How can you have a family?"
Well sure, you can have a family.
But balance is kind of
like, I feel like balance
is like a made up word.
It's like invented by corporations
to make their employees
think that they're happy.
It's like you've got this
balance, you could work
at Microsoft or something here in Seattle.
- [Chase] There's like 10 Microsoft people
in the audience.
- That's right, no
disrespect to Microsoft.
Let's pick another company.
Microsoft's a great company.
- [Chase] One out of every
five people in Seattle
works for Microsoft.
- That's right, and it's
like you got this thing,
and maybe you love your job.
And if you love your job, that's great.
But I hear from a lot
of dissatisfied people
at some of these big companies.
And they write in, "I'm reading your blog
"from my cubicle.
"I have this good job and
I've got my health insurance.
"I've got free yoga every Thursday,
"but I'm not really ..."
- [Chase] Fulfilled.
- Right, I'm not really fulfilled.
So for me I guess I'm much more interested
in that word: fulfilled.
So how can you live a fulfilled life?
You can live a fulfilled life
and still pay your bills.
Lots of creative people do it.
Lots of unconventional
people do it, and I would say
if anything it's actually
much more common now
than it used to be.
When I first started
working online 15 years ago,
I didn't know a lot of other
people who were doing that.
My friends thought I was
selling drugs or something.
- [Chase] Well you were.
- Well I was, or like
online gambling, whatever.
Parents have no idea how the
internet works and stuff.
But now it's much more common.
So I don't really like
the word balanced myself.
- [Chase] So what we'd like to do is
we want to replace the word,
like living a balanced
life is not the goal.
The goal is living a fulfilled life.